de nouveaux projets intéressants je vais
faire le prochain film de paul brozek ya
pas un rôle pour ta soeur tu peux la
soutenir un peu plus de 90 e play a été
parfaite pour le rôle
je vais pas vous ennuyer longtemps ont
trouvé quelque chose mais arrête tu es
chez toi ici
toi tu vas bien envoyé je contemple ce
serait non c'était juste pour savoir si
vous aviez eu des nouvelles concernant
le casting vous allez faire venir nos
plaisirs et nos intérêts non on va pas
au parent on restera pas longtemps
pourquoi tu viens ici mais vous allez
devoir
une victime peut-être bien plus perverse
que son bourreau si elle est consentante
je suis d'elektra sur le tournage s'est
jamais conseillé besoin de figures qu'on
s'a toit pour changer tu le mérites
arrête de me dire ce que je dois faire
j'essaie de comprendre et comprendre
quoi parce que ça me fait à moi de
devoir lui mentir
que tu appelles ton mec t'as fait
tellement mal qu'on peut même pas sans
parler c'est ça que vous voulez
comprendre que tu as à faire [ __ ]
c'est parce que tu avais prévu
saint patrick est à peine mec t'as pas
de costard riom
perry en mode à
[Musique]